special shout-out to the dad sitting
with his kid in the movie theater pretty
close to me there's this hit that's
gonna come in the movie it's a really
violent one it's gonna be really bloody
and everyone knows that he leaves his
kid whispers something his kid goes like
this I can only assume he was like you
know how parents do only problem was is
at the end of the movie and the kid had
already gotten a hardcore anatomy lesson
from the movie involving blood and bone
and spraying and the shattering of the
human body and skull so I admire you
making that call dad out there that I
don't actually know better late than
never but you're gonna have to walk home
with the participation award best I can
do all right let's review this bloodbath
[Music]
Rambow last blood so Rambo last blood is
a pretty simple premise is gonna be a
very simple review Rambo settled down on
this farm he has a nice butt he's more
of a father figure to her this nice goes
to Mexico gets snatched up by these guys
who drug and sell and traffic women now
Rambo is gonna go down there and do what
Rambo does in a nutshell shaving some
stuff off here and there first I was
like okay this is like taken with Rambo
little did I know it's like home alone
with Rambo because when he first goes
down there you think all right it's go
from here to the end of the movie which
is not a long movie it's just gonna be
bloodbath bloodbath bloodbath end it's
not really like that it breaks it up and
you're like I gotta wait a little longer
for the warpath all right and then the
movie does kind of slow down at a point
which is the bummer because that's when
you know that Rambo wants to be
unleashed like farmer John is gone you
see the eye of the tiger I'm not trying
to make these puns they're just
happening you're like all right Rambo
and Lee [ __ ] doesn't quite happen then
it kind of it does slow down it slows
down in a way that I didn't feel like it
needed to slow down granted in that
slowdown mode there is a part in the
movie where I was like oh this is
actually sad I didn't expect that I
didn't expect this movie to be this it's
touching then it gets to the point and
then taken on the bad guys and the blood
and the spring and the heads popping
that's what I remember about the last
Rambo movie - it was just kind of slow
until that last act in that 50 Cal
senior like oh [ __ ] it's not actually as
fulfilling as the 50 Cal same Rambo
still in god mode though like there's no
stopping this guy once he starts so
you're not there for like oh it's a
close fight you're there to watch Rambo
really end lives so I supposed I was
while you're there I can't qualify why
you're there so you need to know why
you're here
like in my ad astra review when i said a
slow burn if it's not your thing this
movie's not gonna be your thing if a
rage-fueled third act bloodbath is not
your thing Rambo last blood will not be
your thing and I've seen some people say
some things about this movie that I just
I don't see my gods promoting toxic
masculinity I mean this movie is
masculine it's very manly yes
rage-filled
there's a lot of rage a lot of lot of
bloodthirsty rage but sometimes this is
such rage necessary like the scenarios
there are these scumbags this group of
scumbags they capture drugged prostitute
and traffic women against their well no
one also do anything about it someone
should but you can own by the way
they're armed to the teeth so take a
friend
let me build my dream team Who am I
gonna take with me you or you exactly
necessary [ __ ] I'm surprised Hollywood
even [ __ ] lit this one what's what's
the next ramble gonna be if they make it
it's just called Rambo last blood but
what if they make Rambo last blood again
but kicking a door just you've been
served
oh [ __ ] I'm being sued by Rambo crazy
who see you guys in the end Rambo last
blood it's not a character piece or
anything like that it's like
surprisingly touching and apart yes if
you're going in there like will the
characters were a little light this is
not that time I liked how it started a
live scene where Rambo was it does slow
down a little bit in the second act then
the third act hits and you're like okay
I'll say Rambo last blood I thought it
was a good time no alcohol required and
now comes the part where I thank the
sponsor of this video and give you
nuggets of wonder and greatness because
this video is brought to you by skills
share skills share is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills illustration
graphic design photography creative
writing animation fine art music film
and video and a lot more lifestyle they
have stuff for lifestyle and premium
membership gives you unlimited access so
you can join the classes in community
that's right for you whether you want to
gain new skills or sharpen the skills
you have whether it's for a career or
maybe you're an enthusiast as we're all
movie fans here of course I'm gonna
recommend the film and video course they
even have a section dedicated to Adobe
Premiere Pro and how to use it I could
have used that that's the actual editor
that I use for my videos if Skillshare
had existed when I started YouTube would
have been helpful I just had to limp
along and learn as I went so if you do
that you're automatically starting your
journey with more skills than I had when
I started an annual subscription the
skill share cost less than $10 a month
so whether you're looking to sharpen
your skills as a YouTube content creator
or you're looking to be the next
Spielberg skill share is a great and
affordable step on that journey so thank
you again this skill share for
sponsoring this sign up through the link
below and get yourself to three months
of skill share get those skills
alright so Rambo less blood have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]